this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
and we're back with a brand new exciting
episode of mark cautiously reviewing
anime while praying to every single god
that he has a job when he wakes up
tomorrow i wish i was joking and not
even that right there's a fight in this
video that i'm gonna cover which i know
might take will have people looking to
castrate me but hey jokes on you toei
already beat you to it there are some
incredible fights and shown in some
iconic moments that have stayed the test
of time moments like the final battle in
cowboy bebop the final revelation of
what exactly was in aaron jaeger's
basement and look even toei has produced
some of the most awe-inspiring moments
in all of the culture with literally
saving aches and goku transforming
finally into the legendary
my point is naruto is one of the most
iconic animes to ever anime and these
stories that i'll be covering today show
us exactly why it's held up so fondly by
those that have read it so without
further preamble i'm totally not mark
and this is my blind review of payne's
assault in the painful wonderful and
incredible masashi kishimoto's naruto
let's get it
[Applause]
so the batman will be batmanning his way
onto our collective theater screens next
month and in light of this fact i've
decided to do what i've never done
before actually attempt to learn
anything about batman i've seen a couple
of the newer films and none of the ones
before 2008 which i think gives me a
rare perspective over the last couple of
weeks i've been reading a bunch of
batman comics to build up my knowledge
of the character and over the final two
weeks of this month i'll be making two
videos wherein i review every single
batman film ever made and yes that
includes everything from the latest in
the dc cinematic universe to
whatever this is and so i hope you all
will join me on this journey starting
next week see you there
[Music]
last time i covered the attachy
storyline which came to a shocking and
brilliant climax that story had focused
a tremendous amount on the dynamic
between sasuke and his brother and with
good reason it needed the space to tell
that story and to be honest the
beginning of this next act suffers from
that decision slightly only slightly
however and i'll get into that in a
second firstly however i'd like to
unpack jiraiya's death and why i love
the way it was handled and also to share
some thoughts i had concerning a
particular decision i found
strange
first the good the scenes showcasing
tsunadi and naruto discovering jiraiya's
fate and their grieving respectively
with the news were appropriately tragic
yet beautiful when kishimoto dedicates
time to quietly exploring our
character's more vulnerable sides i
genuinely think he really shines as a
mangaka furthermore i really like the
idea of leaving behind a riddle or
cipher for naruto that requires solving
which in this particular arc acted as a
very natural means for shikamaru to
reach out to naruto personally for help
in solving this cipher revealing a
conversation that speaks to the
responsibilities of growing up that they
both need to face shonen as a genre is
always dealing with and concerning
itself with children coming of age but
there isn't normally a dedication to
what one should do once those years are
over and where they need to find
fulfillment in that part of their lives
having turned 30 recently i found myself
resonating with that message a lot that
drive to mentor the next generation to
be the ones who buy the ramen rather
than being the snot-nosed little kids as
he calls it in other words it's time to
grow up and to stop sulking we need more
stories to glorify these more mature
parts of our lives as i think there's
somewhat of a stigma for people that
once you get over a certain age that
it's all downhill from there when in
actuality it's all about perspective but
hey what do i know i'm just an old man
anyways those were all my favorite parts
of the ending that really spoke to me
there was however one aspect to it that
while a technical issue still didn't
really feel convincing to me as i
mentioned i really like the idea of
having to figure out how to decipher
this cipher it's a nice mystery to keep
us entertained while we deal with the
emotional outpouring on behalf of
jiraiya however when it came to
deciphering that code my first thought
when i saw it was oh those numbers must
refer to page numbers in his makeout
series of books right but then my second
thought was no that's dumb there's no
way an author would have a comprehensive
knowledge of the exact words that begin
each and every page in his novel off the
top of his head in the heat of battle if
he got one thing wrong then it wouldn't
have worked at all and okay look i know
this might sound unreasonable but look
let's take for example this script i'm
running right now or better yet the
attack on titan script i wrote earlier
last year that monster was over 60 pages
and bear in mind still not as long as
his novels and i worked on it for months
despite however it being shorter and
therefore easier to remember than those
pages from his book series i couldn't
tell you what the first word on the
first page of that script is heck i
couldn't even tell you what the first
word of this script is and i wrote that
yesterday with that said however it is a
cute idea and i like how naruto provides
the insight necessary for them to solve
the code wherein jarya explains that the
warning control is not among the group
in pain alright time for naruto sage
training
[Music]
as i've said numerous times before i'm a
massive fan of trainiacs i think they
add a lovely bit of variety in a story
to break up the constant talking and
fighting while continuously feeding into
the themes of the greater narrative this
part is no different and what i did
notice during this one was once again
despite naruto and sasuke's paths having
diverged in a very significant way
earlier in time their core story beats
are still in sync together somewhat take
for example the last two arcs both
sasuke and naruto have lost people
profoundly important to them on a
fundamental level in diametrically
opposed ways that both have led the
young pupils to receive significant
enhancements to their prior abilities
thanks to their loved one's passing both
of which they would in a heartbeat
return to life in exchange for those
newly acquired powers we've explored
sasuke's predicament already in the last
video so this arc in turn shifts the
focus to naruto once again as we follow
his tutelage under the toad hermit in
terms of mechanical differences once
again i'm a massive fan of what this new
ability means for naruto moving forward
and i love how naruto's pre-existing
abilities allow him to advance quickly
in this complex crash course in sen
jutsu this idea of being able to derive
power from nature and the world around
him is so cool and the means with which
naruto later learns to apply this
technique in ways never before seen by
even his master speaks to both the past
of this series and indeed naruto as a
character himself someone that's capable
of inventing an option c when someone
gives him two options he doesn't agree
with this is a sign of a naive mindset
working in a positive fashion i think
which again works in great contrast to
what sasuke ends up doing towards the
beginning of this arc i believe
following his acquisition of the a tale
spirit and the use of the newfound power
courtesy of his brother sasuke explains
to his fellow uchiha and akatsuki member
why he can be trusted in doing what's in
line with the akatsuki mission and to go
against his brother's wishes of
protecting kanoa and to be honest it
reads is pretty juvenile and overly
simplistic considering everything he's
been through almost to an unbelievable
extent i understand his motivations and
his reasoning on a technical level but
at this point he should realize that
things are often more complicated than
they might appear to be that was the
entire point of his misunderstanding
with his brother and while he might
believe that he more than likely does
have a greater handle on the reality of
the current circumstances the fact that
he's moving forward with this line of
thinking without any hesitation just
proves that he still has so much more to
learn which will be entertaining once
naruto and he inevitably clash down the
line and look okay i know you're waiting
for me to talk about the big big fight
that's coming up but one small thing
first
now i know cousin it from the adams
family is real hashtag yasqueen squad
goals but it's time to get trimmed up
with manscape's new lawnmower 4.0
electric trimmer you get this wonderful
waterproof shaver and more when you
purchase their new performance package
4.0 along with it comes the crop
preserver ball deodorant and the crop
reviver ball toning spray to keep you
smelling fresh all damn day but did you
know that for a limited time only when
you pick up the performance package 4.0
you also get two free gifts the shed
travel bag and the manscaped
anti-chafing boxers these cooling boxer
briefs might actually be one of the
coolest parts of this collection what's
the point in manscaping your bits like a
pro if you're just gonna throw on some
rags afterwards not only are manscaped
boxers extra comfy but they have fancy
crop cooling technology to keep you cool
and dry all day long the fabric's super
soft and comes in a wide range of sizes
all the way up to triple xl and what's
neat is that you get to opt into their
peak hygiene plan which means you'll get
a new pair every cycle straight to your
door if all that sounds good then head
over to manscape.com and use promo code
not mark 20 for 20 off free
international shipping and two free
gifts
underwear
to your door your paws will thank you
bye speaking more broadly for a second
about this ark's pacing there's a lot of
bouncing around to different points of
view early in this arc we get naruto's
sage training which i like sasuke's
acquisition of the a tale spirit his
conversation with the akatsuki members
following that that dude's community
trying to track down the a tale spirit
in him those same folks making a plan to
staging summit tsunami trying to figure
out uriah's message and we also have
payne's attack on kanoa and while i can
appreciate that these are all necessary
points of view and do serve the story in
fact i just didn't find most of them
very interesting at all once here i
think when it comes to what this arc
contains and what the last arc contains
that being two massive battles it's
natural to have all the exposition and
busy work taken care of between the more
hyped moments to allow space for them to
breathe and the bigger the battles the
more exposition that needs to be
squeezed in in between and unfortunately
this is that case
which is reasonable it just so happens
that this section unfortunately is
sandwiched between the two biggest
battles in the story so far and i think
the pacing suffered quite a lot during
these early chapters as a result was it
boring
kind of was it worth what we got after
this oh my god yes
[Music]
pain versus kanoa payne's invasion of
canoga kore is the opening act of what
ends up being one of the biggest and
best fights in the series so far and
maybe because i'm a big fan of naruto as
a character but i sincerely enjoyed this
more than sasuke versus itachi and i
loved that fight but perhaps it's not a
fair comparison because this one had so
many different people fighting to hold
the line waiting for naruto to finish
his training and to save the day there
are tons of moving parts in this one
kicking things off with different
battles held across the greater village
area the use of strategy and the
implementation and acquisition of new
information turns all of these fights on
their respective heads with each
individual understanding that each
encounter could be their last against
these monsters and that if they are
going to lose their lives here they may
as well do so while gaining precious
intel to help enhance the village's
chances of survival and this
unfortunately applies to everyone from
konohamaru all the way to the great
kakashi
the quick exchange between pain and
kakashi once again despite naruto and
sasuke having steamrolled ahead in terms
of ability highlights the fact that
kakashi is still managing to remain a
remarkably resourceful and focused
warrior for konoha utilizing brilliant
strategy through very convincing clones
to drag out more intel from the
situation regarding pain for the use of
others in this battle furthermore these
more desperate measures serve to act as
a tremendously effective means of
building tension i mean even kakashi is
pulling out all the stops and he's
struggling but as i mentioned there are
a host of different battles taking place
all over the village with a real sense
of dread and hopelessness hanging in the
air particularly when choza is thought
to be dead and kakashi sacrifices his
own safety in order to allow choji to
relay that message that intel they
gathered back to tsunade and once he got
there tsunami could sense chose his
energy but no one else's it's at this
point kishimoto once again leans on his
wonderful sensibilities with regards
these more emotional or sentimental
moments seldom as they are when they do
show up they really hit their mark
having grown up being treated as though
he was an outsider despite pain
demanding to know the location of naruto
despite him threatening everyone's lives
the people of kanoa won't sell out
naruto as we're reminded of all he's
achieved through the eyes of kanoa's
citizens it's a brilliant lens for which
to view this part of the battle through
seeing what naruto means to them and how
far this story has progressed as a
result speaking of progression
all right i gotta say that was really
sick and getting to see this kid now
having grown up some once again speaks
to the fostering of this new generation
shikamaru touched on earlier as well
naruto gave this kid some of his time
and guidance and now he's capable of
performing feats such as this the
rasengan is a [ __ ] crazy powerful
move to pull out as a surprise attack
all right but okay
switching gears for a second and
checking in with naruto he's after
encountering a small teeny tiny problem
due to the fox spirit unlike uriah the
toads can't rest on his shoulders to
facilitate this technique's charge time
which means now naruto is faced with a
specific problem unique to him without
someone on his shoulder to focus that
energy on his behalf he now needs to
figure out a way of staying still in
combat in order to focus on gathering
that energy without getting killed by
pain easier said than done right and
okay somewhat troublingly pain
eventually finds out where naruto is
after which
the unthinkable happens
naruto versus pain
chaos raining from above the entire
village destroyed and even tsunade in
way over her head trying to protect as
many people as she can from the
onslaught as the dust clouds fade
their naruto stands ready to lay down
his life for all of those that afforded
him the time to prepare with theirs
there's a wonderfully tragic but
exciting moment that shows itself as the
ignition for this fight specifically now
that naruto has mastered this natural
chakra business he can sense everyone's
energy but
not kakashi's he calmly asks if he's on
a mission elsewhere and it's all to no
response he knows his fate a younger
weaker and more naive naruto would have
in this instance exploded in anger
throwing caution to the wind as well as
his strategy practically assuring his
defeat and securing everyone else's
downfall but it's different now he's
grown up as we saw through the eyes of
the villagers earlier naruto is no
longer a child and it's time for him to
prove that in the grandest of ways and
in doing so setting an example for the
next generation choosing to carefully
channel his anger into attacking the
pain gang and boy does he do just that
the opening gambit of this conflict is
honestly brilliant and full of just the
right amount of determination motivation
and strategy everything i love in a good
narrative fight we know what naruto is
fighting for we know how far he's come
we are currently learning all the
strengths and weaknesses of the pain
group and naruto's strategy once again
is something only he can manage to pull
off thanks to his seemingly bottomless
supply of chakra leaving shadow clones
behind him to charge away elsewhere as
batteries for the sage energy it's a
remarkably good strategy turning a
weakness into a strength a very naruto
thing to do and the best part of this
entire opening to this fight is that the
guy who has been stealing all the
jinshuriki power from all the folks in
the pain group manages to get a hold of
naruto himself this would normally be a
catastrophic failure on naruto's part
and while it was a mistake like always
naruto finds a way of turning something
negative into a positive because naruto
needed to be still in order to gather
that sage jutsu that wasn't a viable
strategy for approaching this battle he
would have been open to attack however
in that hold with this guy he can do
just that stay still which then led to
that pain guy absorbing too much sage
jutsu thus turning him into a frog
creature because he can't control it
that was such a [ __ ] creative and
cool moment with a decent depth of cause
and effect and while it still fresh my
mind at this moment in time it is my
favorite switcheroo in the story
finally it comes to light exactly what
is happening with regards to the pain
puppet and who the puppeteer is i
thought it was really cool to finally
get a chance to see nagato since we
haven't really seen him since the
flashbacks with jiraiya though he looks
like [ __ ] now i like the thematic
significance of his mission through pain
nagato explains to naruto his vision for
the world and in the process really puts
a bunch of conflict into naruto's mind
through pain both literally and
metaphorically nagato is showing the
world what his vision for the future is
and what justice he wants to bring
[Music]
without naruto willing to make a move
hinata jumps in confesses her respect
and love for naruto
he's already dead
and gets taken out
[Music]
oh my god he's got bones on this looks
kind of awkward but surprisingly cool i
didn't think it would look cool but it
actually does in execution with the body
of the fox building itself around naruto
as the tail sprout it's a really cool
visual indication of progression towards
a known endpoint which i would imagine
is the fully realized fox spirit in its
physical form but okay we finally got
into the moment that you've all been
waiting for
the meme fight
okay i'm gonna switch on my camera for
this bit i'll be talking a lot about
animation and i'm not trusting japan's
copyright laws at this moment in time
let it be known that in preparation for
this section of the video i have read
the manga and viewed the corresponding
episodes of the anime that this
controversial piece of animation has
stemmed from i recognize that i will be
attempting to give my personal opinion
on the subjective but widely discussed
topic on the internet but i guess i'm a
maverick like that with that said i will
try to ground my reasoning in terms as
uncontroversial as i can and i will do
so by trying to answer the question is
this a good depiction of this fight
there are of course those of you out
there that think obviously no and
obviously yes to that answer so let's
take a closer look for me what makes a
fight scene great is multi-faceted story
animation artwork and yes those are two
separate things pacing immersiveness and
overall storyboarding or direction of a
scene and interestingly the animation
plays a role in all of these aspects
when it comes to animation quality i
think it's a massively impressive
showcase of an animator's skills in that
department the animator in question here
that worked on this scene was shinga
yamashita and azer you've seen his work
before in the past and not just from
this scene in fact he's since gone on to
direct and composite for other anime i
mean he has been incredibly successful
with the openings of jiu jitsu kaizen
but that's jiu jitsu kaizen that's not
naruto and this has become a beast into
and of itself i had seen this clip of
animation and i knew people didn't like
it however it is important to keep in
mind when i say animation that i am not
referring to the piece's likeness to the
characters animation is the illusion of
movement and to varying degrees
different series have iconic examples of
this and
examples of tragically poor animation
also sometimes in the biggest of
properties in japan one of my favorite
animators that worked on dragon super
back in the day was a man by the name of
naoki tate hello there
he too was a controversial artist
because some people loved him and others
hated him and once again it boiled down
entirely to what one as an audience
member was looking for if they were
looking for crazy dynamic animation then
tate was their guy if they were looking
for model sheet accuracy then he wasn't
and this fight here with payne seems to
tell the very same story but in an even
more exaggerated fashion the gestures
the smears the squash and stretch is all
there in aggressive effect and as a
result the scene is filled with a ton of
energy it's exciting it's dynamic it's
energetic it feels alive and moreover
for the most part not too dissimilar to
other big action episodes within this
series of naruto however with that said
let's take a look at the other side of
this coin character likeness and its
importance i am a big fan of sakuga or
high quality animation from japan i'm
interested in the subject and i like
studying it a little more closely than
the average bear and taking that into
consideration if someone values
character arc consistency more than
animation and movement then that's not
only perfectly reasonable it's probably
how most people feel too and with good
reason the purpose of animation is to
enhance the story that's been told
through it and one important way of
achieving that desired effect is by
suspending the audience's disbelief for
them to get invested in the characters
and forget that they're watching
animation however i believe one could
very easily make the argument that if
any animation takes someone out of the
story and the story is what you're there
for then to those people that animation
would have failed in living up to its
purpose in other words if in this fight
with pain you found it distracting to
the point of it taking you out of the
story or fight that was taking place
then that animation despite it being
intentionally exaggerated and
technically impressive fails to serve
the primary purpose of animation for
that person which is to tell the story
in a dramatic fashion in keeping with
the tone of the manga but okay i've
explained why i think some people like
it and why some people hate it but what
do i think well it's complicated when it
came to this approach i think there's a
tremendous amount of talent on display
when it comes to conveying movement and
a sense of energy the timing is really
nice and all that jazz and i'm also a
fan of simple shapes in order to
facilitate movement so from a
philosophical standpoint i appreciate
the approach taken however the moments
or moment that people seem to take issue
with even i have to admit feels like
they are pushing the envelope far too
far when it comes to some of the
exaggerations again this isn't evident
of poor animation quality certainly not
as i believe the animation to be quite
brilliant here it is however i think a
result either of not enough time
reserved for corrections or perhaps not
the right direction for that scene at
least i think so while as i mentioned
that i appreciate the philosophy behind
the approach taken i think it veered too
far into looney tune territory when it
came to some of the choices made which
ultimately took me completely out of the
moment that these scenes were trying to
deliver for so in short i think the
artist that worked on this was
incredibly talented and i think that the
vast majority was perfectly within the
realms of what the show had produced
before but i do however think that the
vision shinjo yamashita had for part of
this final product was perhaps too far
outside of what many of us including me
consider to be within the boundaries of
reasonable artistic license when i saw
this i wasn't thinking about how awesome
the fight was i wasn't thinking about
the story i was instead thinking about
the animation and how i felt that it
didn't match the show's overall approach
which distracted me from my primary
reason for watching anime the story but
that's just my take let me know what you
think in the comment section down below
personally i think there's a happy
medium to be found here that would
please more people than this ultimately
did without alienating the sakura fans
take no kitate's best moments from
dracula
these are perfect examples of this sort
of loose minimalistic animation being
corrected to accommodate for both
stylistic consistency as well as a
tremendous energy in animation and so i
think if yamashita had some of his cuts
corrected for model correctness it
wouldn't have created as big of a
shitstorm as it did otherwise online but
that's just my two cents also i think
i'll probably keep up the facecam for
the rest of this video because lord
knows i am recording this review way too
late and my editor is tired i'll
probably be doing more face cam in the
future too to help distance myself from
material that has in the past nuked my
channel
speaking broadly about the fight for a
second i thought the action was
bombastic and the contrast between how
the fox fights versus how naruto fights
is appropriately stark it helps to
reinforce the dedication to strategy and
technique naruto the person is and how
inconsiderate the fox is to the village
and world around him interested only in
destroying what stands in opposition to
him which as it happens helps to elevate
one of the most surprising scenes i've
yet come across
[Music]
for the last two volumes this story has
built up to one gigantic climax within
this fight and interestingly kishimoto
subverts this expectation through this
scene naruto's first meeting with his
father the fourth hokage and as i'm sure
many of you are aware at this point i've
never been a massive fan of fight scenes
unless they have compelling ties to the
narrative by way of mystery or whatever
but i am and always have been a massive
fan of quiet introspective moments full
of character-rich dialogue and
that's exactly what this is during this
encounter the fourth hokage is collected
compassionate and wise while naruto is
reasonably upset and elated at what he's
learned he physically lashes out at his
father before basking momentarily in the
fact that he's the fourth hokage's son
which is again such a naruto thing to do
particularly during a time where he's
made to feel confused and uncertain
thanks to pain he feels like a child
there's a neat conversation about the
philosophy surrounding what naruto is
struggling with what pain has taught him
his motivations were and in response to
that the fourth hokage explains that
where there's love there will be hate
and the duty of the shinobi is to fight
the hatred before it turns into pain and
suffering the fourth tells naruto that
he doesn't know the answer to his
problems but believes that naruto will
find the answer himself before sealing
away the fox spirit and leaving naruto
to return to the battle the words of
encouragement echoing in his ears from
kakashi jiraiya and now his father he
stands once more to the challenge that
pain presents him that nagato presents
him once again there are some great
visuals where the benefits of the sage
technique even when not in use become
apparent thanks to that chakra being
used in place of his own natural supply
naruto's clones explode onto the page in
a beautiful spread which again reminds
me of the story's beginning when he
first used that technique setting
himself up for the rasangan what a
brilliant move the climax to this
conflict is instead of action a
conversation a philosophical
conversation wherein naruto expresses a
desire nagato explains his pain and
naruto shows his maturity again
something i need to make clear is that
my videos aren't a substitute for the
original material so i won't be
explaining exactly what said but instead
giving my impressions on it but i think
right from the beginning when naruto
expresses that he did not see his defeat
of pain as a victory i thought again
that this is another wonderful step
towards the theme of maturity for naruto
but the story also never shied away from
the ugliness of hatred he can't just
ignore that nagato killed jaraya and
kakashi but his memory of his master's
parting lesson can stop him from
continuing this cycle of violence
reinforcing that it is a choice that you
can choose not to hurt people to not
cause more pain
[Music]
story was interesting but a line that
stood out to me was this
i will rule this world and make the
suffering stop
this is a very naive and overly
simplistic view of how the world should
be under him naruto's journey in this
arc has been about him accepting his
role in becoming an adult needing to
learn patience and to think things
through and to prepare the world for the
next generation and in a way that's
exactly what nagato wants to do too
however with a lot more purposeful
suffering jiraiya is quoted as saying a
person matures grows up when you
experience pain and as i'm sure you've
noticed this is a perfect continuation
to the themes of growing up and maturity
at play here too for naruto the
situations regarding nagato and his
issue surrounding the illusion of peace
for these larger nations following times
of bloodshed is a really interesting
perspective and a tragically honest
experience he and many others have
shared and naruto doesn't necessarily
have any solution for it other than that
he won't give up and he will find a
solution to this problem admitting that
he still hates him but understands why
he is the way that he is and most
importantly decides not to hurt him
naruto asks for nakato to believe that
he won't harden with pain to believe
that he won't grow resentful or vengeful
that he will earnestly seek out peace in
the name of his master and for the good
of the world where nagato's pain pushed
him to embrace a negative path naruto's
helped him to embrace a positive one
with this conversation speaking to
jiraiya's lesson 2 nagato naruto has
every reason to hate and despise nagato
for everything that he's done however
after hearing his story naruto can use
his own life experiences his own pain to
empathize and sympathize with nagato
much the same way he did with gara
during the tuning exams thus avoiding
conflict naruto's pain was a source of
peace in this instance this manages to
reach nagato and while this ending might
feel much like nagato's thoughts on the
matter a little overly simplistic as a
set of lessons to live by i think
there's some great stuff here that's all
rooted in naruto as he exists as a
character i'm not sure i'm a massive fan
of the resurrecting of shinobi and
people who died during the battle as it
does remove a lot of the consequences
and followed from this arc but is it
worth it for when naruto arrives back at
kanoa to a hero's welcome i think
absolutely the lonely boy that once
sought after recognition and
acknowledgement is now the hero of his
village a beloved member of the society
who is now armed with a new perspective
for which to better understand sasuke
who he seems to be destined to collide
with very soon how will this pan out i
don't know but if the off notes are
anything to go by or these volumes that
are slowly dwindling behind me are any
indication it's that we are quickly
heading for the home stretch will it be
good will i like it i don't know
probably but if you do want to continue
with me on this journey please consider
subscribing it costs nothing and means
the world to myself and my team but
that'll do it for this week i've been
toying up mark i'll see you all next
week and
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you